the
situation in afghanistan has
deteriorated and as i said in the house
of commons a few weeks ago
we could see this coming for for some
time and
we'd have to make preparations to to
pull out and that's what's going on now
that moment has now come so in the
course the next few days we will see
the vast bulk of uk
embassy staff officials come back and
we'll step up our efforts to bring back
those afghans who have helped us help
the uk helped international forces
throughout the uh the last 20 years
and uh in addition to the the the 2000
who have already come out and to help
them we're sending out another
team of home office uh officials to to
help them with their their applications
and and get them out
and uh
obviously we are appealing to to those
who uh have
association with uh the uk who who want
to come out uh now to come forward and
identify themselves i think what i would
say at this at this stage is it is very
difficult obviously uh but i think the
uk can be extremely proud of what has
been done in afghanistan over the last
20 years don't forget that the combat
mission ended in in 2014 there isn't a
military
solution
but thanks to the efforts of of the uk
uh armed services uh all the sacrifices
they made uh we have seen uh no al-qaeda
attacks on against the west uh for a
very long time
and there are millions of girls and
young women who've been educated uh in
afghanistan thanks to the efforts of
of the uk and british armed services i
think people can be can be very proud of
that but things are going in the
opposite direction now how worried are
you that afghanistan is going to become
a breeding ground for terrorists and
isn't there an argument to go in the
opposite direction and to perhaps have a
permanent troop presence once again
i think we've got to be realistic about
the abilities of the
the uk or any power to impose a military
solution a combat
solution in afghanistan
what we certainly can do
is work with all our partners uh
in the region and around the world who
share an interest in uh with us in
preventing afghanistan from once again
becoming a breeding ground for terror i
think anybody uh in government in kabul
is going to recognize that the the west
the uk have a permanent interest in
making sure that that does not happen
and so we are going to use our
diplomatic our our political our
overseas development aid budget uh
leverage uh to make sure uh that we
exert what pressure we can and uh we
will continue to do that but i think the
idea of a of a military or a combat
solution is uh is is not the one that we
should be pursuing right now it's a grim
reality as we approach the 20th
anniversary of 9 11. what do you say to
military families who lost their loved
ones in afghanistan some of whom are now
saying they feel that their loved ones
died in vain
i
first of all i i
share their
uh the sorrow of all the families who've
lost loved ones over the last 20 years
the the 457
british troops who were
serving men and women who were killed in
the in that conflict uh many of them in
in helmand uh i thank them uh for the
immensity of their sacrifice thank their
families uh for what they have they've
gone through and
i know how they must feel at the moment
but i must say that i don't believe it
was
in vain because i do think when you look
back at what has happened over the last
uh 20 years there was a massive effort
to deal with a particular problem uh
that everybody will remember after 9 11
and that was successful
and to a very large extent the threat
from al-qaeda on the streets of
our capital around the uk around the
whole of the west uh was greatly greatly
reduced and there was the further
advantage
that millions i think three million uh
girls young women were educated uh who
would not otherwise have been educated
and so what i would say to to to those
families now is uh i i understand what
you what you feel but i believe that it
was uh it was right it was it was worth
it and what we must do now
is not uh turn our backs
on afghanistan but continue as a member
of the security council uh
someone a country deeply involved in the
strategic future of the area to work
with our partners and make sure
that the government of kabul does not
allow
that country again to be a breeding
ground for terror ben wallace has
suggested it was a mistake for the u.s
to withdraw troops he said the doha deal
was a rotten
deal do you agree with your defense
secretary and if so why weren't we
pushing against it at the time
the
american government obviously has
decided to take a particular course of
action and that is one that uh has the
inevitable logical consequence that i
set out in the house of commons
several weeks ago and the situation has
now evolved in exactly the direction
that we we said it would we have to deal
with those consequences